so you're kind of like around the like
you're really coming up on like common
drops resurrection and like can I borrow
a dollar and like they're super early
common sense [__] like so my high school
yeah a high school yeah well
yeah so I graduated in 2000 I'm trying
to think of what albums I I had early on
like Reasonable Doubt drop I had to uh
rake Raekwon only build me a few links
that Naz verse on Verbal Intercourse I
didn't know what he was talking about as
a kid but that [__] sounded Fly And I
memorized it uh
but I I like novelty stuff back then too
as a kid I remember having uh Deion
Sanders must be the money uh 95 south I
moved there like that [__] that you know
the Deion Sanders yeah yeah man there
was a CD that I had as a kid and it was
um every diff it was like a compilation
and every song was a different NBA
player rapping oh yeah and like Jason
Kidd had a song [__] Mitch Richmond
had a song it was just like terrible
music but I bought it because I was like
a basketball fan I was like wait I could
hear
all these NBA players rap it was a bad
bad purchase at the end of the day but
yeah do you think
Shaq did it all right he has some joints
he's just having a bet is it more about
them having is this who in the room with
them to get it yeah cause I think Shaq
had some [__] yeah you had to you know
to uh you can't stop dude
good presents too just yeah black
thought on [__] he had he he before once
that um Jay-Z Nas beef got out of hand
you could actually go back and Shaq had
a song with both of them on the same
record yeah yeah so was it uh these
basketball players were they really bad
I think Shaq was actually a decent
rapper yeah or with the other ones
though were they necessarily bad or they
just had bad a r i don't know did you
ever hear Kobe song
uh uh I did but it doesn't it's not good
yeah and then you have like [__] AI
who was dropping like you know he had he
was like Allen Iverson AKA Jules and he
had an album that was just all kinds of
[__] Street [__] you know I think he
might have gotten in trouble for putting
that album out I don't remember he was
talking some crazy [__] as like a
millionaire as like a guy who's got his
own Reebok shoe
yeah people got to express man sometimes
there's some stuff that you can't say
with the dribble and a jump shot you
know you gotta just get in the stew and
let that [__] fly for sure you gotta you
know hey I don't want to say this with
20 000 people around me I'm gonna say
this by myself who is your in your like
uh go-to when it comes to artists that
you're you've you've got you know
obviously building friendships with
where you can send them records and get
their opinion back on them
uh
uh open mike Eagle I sent him a lot of
stuff
um
but yeah I said open my Google some
stuff
who else
I was sending I was seeing a lot of
people stuff when I made my track kept
about three it used to be called Kawaii
freestyle it was like 14 minutes long
and I was it was November 2020 so
pandemic pandemic oh yeah that's the
perfect time that I would never send
people just a 14 Minute Freestyle now
but I was so hyped about it and I just
felt I felt the progression and just
liked how the track sounds and I was
just sending out to everybody it was
just like hey look I can rap for 14
minutes it was it wasn't all cool he's
we had it yeah it definitely has you
know we cut it down but it was an
exciting time I was sending that to
everybody I I knew at the at the time I
said that's a hell of people just hey
look I sent this [__]
um but yeah might give some good good
feedback on stuff and
uh
I said stuff to fly low sometimes I'll
send you know just see what he thinks
but uh yeah it's been it's been dope man
it's just you know just keep on learning
progressing
I want to be able to play drums in my
set three five years from now you know
I'm practicing [__] and [__] awesome
pack out there you know that show that
I've been seeing him live though crazy
and I didn't he'd be honest doing the
whole [__] like and I remember seeing
that Pitchfork years back really I
didn't know you could do that I didn't
know that was possible I thought that
was for mother are you playing keys or
playing guitar or are they only on the
mic and that the drink he's just
shredding on the drums while doing all
his verses yeah that [__] is tough yeah
he's an alien for sure so uh yeah man
it's been you know it's dope to learn
and
it's this exciting time man it's for
sure it's time just to work on the work
on the [__] and get in the detail of it